heute die traurigen nachricht dass auch
ein test der todesopfer deutsch war
diese nachricht jetzt also gerade
gekommen wie haben sie gestern abend der
das alles erlebt die nacht auch erlebt
und vor allem jetzt heute diese
nachricht naja ich bin natürlich
schockiert gewesen
vor allen dingen auch weil wir ja in
frankreich schon mal zwei
terroranschläge in den letzten tagen
gehabt haben jetzt kommt einer in wien
dazu auf eine unglaublich perfide art ja
würde morgen gleich mit meinem
österreichischen kollegen telefoniert
dann bekamen wir im laufe des
nachmittags die nachricht dass eines der
opfer eine deutsche frau ist das ist
natürlich noch einmal für uns macht uns
das noch mal betroffen
wir versuchen dann immer erst die
angehörigen zu informieren bevor eine
solche nachricht dann öffentlich gemacht
wird dann natürlich sollen die
angehörigen das nicht aus den medien
erfahren das haben wir getan dass es
auch immer ein sehr trauriger moment
aber insgesamt ist das schrecklich und
es ist natürlich ein thema das uns
beschäftigt dass das was in frankreich
geschehen ist der streit um die
karikaturen dass das noch einmal sich
verschärft und auch in andere länder
übergreift es gibt im moment wohl keinen
zusammenhang sagt mir mein kollege der
darauf hindeutet dass es etwas mit den
karikaturen zu tun hat aber das problem
bei solchen anschlägen ist dass die
gefahr für nachahmungstaten entsteht und
es dann müssen wir im moment sehr sehr
wachsam sein weil natürlich die gefahr
besteht dass überall auf der welt leute
versuchen das nachzuahmen und deshalb
wird die sicherheitsbehörden in
alarmbereitschaft wir tauschen uns
international mit unseren partnern ab um
vorkehrungen zu schaffen um gewappnet zu
sein wobei man dazusagen muss eine
einzelne person die sich das in den kopf
gesetzt hat die das plant ohne dass
größere organisationen oder netzwerke
involviert sind das ist sehr sehr schwer
das im vorfeld aufzudecken
das ist das perfide an solchen
anschlägen eine zeit lang war dieser
terror nicht mehr zum glück so ganz in
unseren köpfen das hatten wir vielleicht
so ein tick verdrängt rechnen sie jetzt
anhand oder anlässlich dieser
drastischen bilder und ereignisse der
letzten nacht wieder mit einer neuen
welle
mit einer terrorwelle möglicherweise
also wir müssen sehr aufmerksam sein
deshalb tauschen wie international auch
alle informationen die wir haben aus das
ist sehr sehr schwer einzelne täter
ausfindig zu machen und zu verhindern
dass solche taten stattfinden deshalb
verstärken wir uns nochmal alle
bemühungen auch im informationsaustausch
international die wir miteinander haben
wir müssen alles dazu beitragen dass die
lage deeskaliert wird dass es nicht noch
weiter öl ins feuer gegossen wird
das ist eine der verantwortlichkeiten
die wir jetzt haben in der
internationalen staatengemeinschaft das
versuchen wir ich habe gestern mit einem
pakistanischen kollegen gesprochen weil
es auch aus pakistan ich mal sagen sehr
sehr harte reaktionen gegeben hat auf
die äußerung von präsident makro und wir
versuchen alle anzusprechen und sie zu
ermuntern dass wir alle unsere
verantwortung gerecht werden denn
niemand wird es solche anschläge wo auch
immer auf der welt passieren
jetzt hat der österreichische
bundeskanzler sowas denn kurz heute im
interview mit uns bereits gesagt dass
man inmitten einer neuen terrorwelle
bereitsteht wie gefährlich ist es jetzt
für uns hier in deutschland gerade was
wissen sie davon den sicherheitsbehörden
und vor allem was können wir in europa
überhaupt aber man hat das gefühl nach
jedem anschlag nach eben nach jeder
terrortat finden politiker die gleichen
worte und danach passiert eigentlich
nicht so richtig werden na ja also es
ist in der vergangenheit schon
unternommen worden auch was die
zusammenarbeit der sicherheitsbehörden
international angeht wir haben ja die
situation dass wir immer darauf
hingewiesen haben etwa auch mit unsere
militärischen engagement im irak dass
der es nicht besiegt ist deshalb zwar
kein eigenes territorium er halte es
nach wie vor anschläge stattfinden und
wie gibt müssen sehr aufmerksam uns mit
der frage auseinandersetzen ist der es
noch in der lage anschläge nicht nur im
irak oder im grenzbereich zu syrien
durchzuführen sondern ist ja auch wieder
in der lage anschläge in europa
durchzuführen und das ist etwas wo wir
mit null toleranz reagieren müssen wo
die sicherheitsbehörden gefordert sind
wo die nachrichtendienste gefordert sind
die informationen die man hat
miteinander auszutauschen um
so gut es geht gewappnet zu sein für all
das was kommt und im moment nach einer
solchen tat unmittelbar danach muss man
immer mit nachahmern rechnen wir haben
zurzeit keine konkreten informationen
dass es in deutschland entwicklung gibt
die darauf hindeuten aber wir müssen
sehr aufmerksam sein
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dir das nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren